ثم جاء دور الممثل الفرنسي كاترين دينوف
التي اختار المهرجان صورتها لتكون ملصقا
رسميا لهذا العام ثم تحدثت عن تضامنها مع
اوكرانيا وتحدثت ببعض كلمات اوكرانيه
افكر قبل كل شيء في اوكرانيا واتمنى كل
السعاده والحريه لهم ويبقى لدينا امل ثم
اعلنت بمعيه الممثل الامريكي عن بدء
المهرجان
[تصفيق]
مهرجان كان السينما الدولي نجوم السينما
العالميه على مدى ايام المهرجان وسيعرض
نحو 100 فيلم من بينها 21 فيلما في
المسابقه الرسميه متعه المشاهده لافلام
كبار صناعه السينما العالميه في مهرجان
كان والذي يستمر حتى السابع والعشرين من
مايو جاري وحضور لافت للسينما العربيه في
المسابقات الرسميه سعد المسعود العربيه
مهرجان كان السينمائي جنوب فرنسا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات